this is usually one of Sydney's most
popular tourist attractions the normally
picturesque Blue Mountains bordering the
outskirts of the city much of it now
decimated by bush fires they've been
burning across large parts of Australia
for months now with flames as high as 70
metres the fire in this region alone has
destroyed an area seven times the size
of Singapore but this isn't just bush
land
it's home for thousands of Australians
fire crews are working tirelessly to
protect residents Robert B Croft is a
former volunteer firefighter he's seen
many bush fires in his time but this one
is different
I've been here for 67 years I've seen a
lot of fires through the mountains
actually in my younger days sport quite
a few fires that I haven't seen so many
out of control back burns the B crops
like so many families here faced a
difficult choice leave everything behind
or stay and potentially put themselves
in danger it's a little bit stressful
but you just gotta remain positive I
suppose it's hard to think of what you
want to keep in everything but just get
what seems important at the time to go
and I'm sure there'll be other things
that you'll think about later but just
be prepared I guess it's just bit bad
timing obviously around the holidays but
what can you do really I've never seen
anything like it
it's quiet it's pretty confronting but
put your heart and everything out to the
volunteers and anything out there for
such extreme conditions some of these
fires have been burning since July but
authorities are warning that these are
catastrophic conditions it's the
combination of extreme heat strong winds
and low humidity that makes a situation
on the ground incredibly dangerous
firefighters are battling the blaze on
the ground and from the air the intense
heat has even generated its own
thunderstorm nearly all the men and
women fighting the fires are volunteers
some haven't seen their families in days
for locals who risk losing almost
everything some are just trying to do
whatever they can it's just been quite
difficult
to get much sleep and it's quite anxious
it's the bees problem just worried this
is just the beginning of summer and many
a fearful of what lies ahead for the
rest of the bushfire season
Jessica Washington al-jazeera Blackheath
Australia